logan allen he's only 23 years old so
he's ready to do it and we're going to
i'm certainly ready to watch him grow i
like the way he threw the ball in his
first outing against kansas city so
here's reynado nunez
this is the first base runner for
detroit with a runner in scoring
position
swing and a missing he struck him out
two away he goes with the slider here
and gets him to chase that pitch looked
like it might have been out of the zone
but ahead in the count and that leaves
it up to jamer candelario 2-2
reaches out sends one to right
naylor's got a long run it's going to
drop in front of him grossman's going to
trot home and the tigers have a
one-nothing lead on the rbi single from
jamer candelario nice
candy stays back there's a good
good slider but it doesn't break down
and then it's down over the heart of
plate candy stays on it naylor cannot
catch it base is loaded two out a 2-2
swing and a miss he struck him out with
a hagget slider and the inning is over
jose uranya reining's in his first start
fairly wild only 39 of 81 pitches were
strikes the 2-2 swinging a miss terrific
slider
and under the bat
of in that at-bat a lefty fernandez
strikes out the 0 for 4 for ramirez last
night first time this season another 0-2
got him looking
terrific first inning for jose uranya
back-to-back strikeouts
jacoby jones
there it is third strikeout for logan
allen two down
robbie grossman hit by a pitch came
around to score the only run of the game
in the first inning
got him looking
grossman rung up 4ks for logan allen
one-nothing tigers indians bat bottom of
the second eddie rosario the cleanup
hitter
nice slaps it the other way and it's
gonna get down
cut off though nicely by grossman
rosario rolling for second base and he's
in there safely with a leadoff double
great hustle right out of the box oh
that was a beautiful
thing right there that piece of hitting
he just served it out there to left
field he was fooled on the pitch he kept
his hands back and you know what this
this doubles gonna be made out of the
batter's box
only a matter of time until he gets
going
he's taking off for third
and no throw
oh baby
he just went for broke
well they never made him stop
he was a one look guy so two walks after
the lead off double and they're loaded
with one out
tops it towards second goodrum goes to
second there's one no play at first the
indians will tie the game as jake bowers
picks up his first rbi on the year
number two hitter willie castro flying
out his first time up
straw kim out swinging
number five already for logan allen
andreas jimenez leads off the bottom of
the third for
cleveland grip the first and it gets by
scope
ximena's on his way to second base and
he'll go in standing with a lead off
double
second straight inning the indians
lead it off with a two
cesar hernandez batting left-handed
and a line driving right field that's
gonna get down for a base hit coming
around third they're gonna wave him home
throw goes to second indians take the
lead
cesar hernandez
with his second run batted in on the
year and he is now three for four this
season with a runner in scoring position
2-1
a little nubber
whorena's got a hurry and got it we
hopped off the mound quickly through a
strike to jonathan scope to barely get
jose ramirez for the first out of the
inning he threw a bullet
shift is on here for the tribe playing
mazzara a left-handed batter to pull he
swings and grounds one to the third
baseman ramirez to the back for one on
to first double play
five six three on the double play to end
the inning 2-1 cleveland
robbie grossman hit by a pitch scored
the tigers only run on the first
ground ball to third and ramirez
with a great play to throw him out two
down
see how everything was just
nicely timed in motion never rushed
threw it on the run and made a perfect
throw
i mean it's right over the back he had
to scoop it and just made it and make it
make it look so easy huh it's 2-1
cleveland with two outs here in the
fifth and now dan petry it'll be daniel
norris big hitter right here with two
ouch
big
got him swinging daniel norris comes in
does his job to get through the fifth
and the new pitcher for cleveland is
brian shaw renato nunez has struck out
and walked he's hitting cleanup
swing and a miss brian shaw strikes out
renato nunez two away
fran reyes
homer three times friday and saturday
line drive deep right field that'll get
down one hops the wall
fran mill gonna have to hurry he's
rolling get into the throw and he's in
there safely toppling over the bag with
a lead-off double
the third lead-off double of the
afternoon here's some ed rosario boy the
indians now have a chance to get some
breathing room
bouncing ball to short there's one
and two
reyes scores on the play and it's now
3-1 cleveland i'll tell you that's
exactly what norris was looking for he
made his pitch
able to get the double play clear the
bases the indians can only put one on
the board there nick wickron
is the third pitcher of the afternoon he
takes over for brian shaw wilson ramos
jonathan scope and no mar mazzara
ramos puts a charge into one in a deep
center field and that ball is gone a
solo blast for wilson ramos three
straight games in which he's homered and
he's brought the tigers to within one
mad power there from the tigers
catcher in the seventh james karen check
on to pitch the eighth for cleveland try
to hold a one run lead he's got the top
of the order tying run aboard to start
the eight willy castro oh for three this
afternoon string and a missy struck him
out
one away so a stolen base for grossman
his second on the year and now the tying
run in scoring position
blew it by him two down
karaczek is a strike away from ending
the inning
by him karen check walks the lead off
man and then strikes out three in a row
runners at second and third nobody out
three to two indians fran mill reyes the
batter
[Applause]
base hit right field
ramirez scores rosario stops at third
and the throw goes to the backstop here
comes eddie he scores the ball still
pounding around the infield like it's
pinball
reyes in the second base
the indians have scored two in the
eighth
they lead it now five to two
and alerio the runner at second scope is
at first tying run at the plate
posse with the 1-1
ground ball two seconds there's one on
to first
book it
a game-ending double play secures the
tribe's first sweep of 21.